hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled innovative genomics and
cold chain solutions for development of
cell and gene therapies i'm susie valdez
of labrutz and i will be your moderator
for today's presentation
i'd like to invite everyone to
participate by submitting your questions
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send
and if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation just click on
that question mark icon on the left
toolbar for further help and submit your
concerns to the ask a question box
now let's get started today's webinar
will be presented by dr elizabeth louis
supervisor of technical applications at
gene whiz a brook life science company
and in her role at gene with dr louis
provides consultation to customers
across the gene whiz genomics solution
including next generation sequencing
gene and dna synthesis and any custom
molecular biology need for a complete
biography of dr elizabeth louis please
click on the biography tab at the top of
your screen dr louis welcome you may now
begin your presentation
thank you for the introduction and thank
you so much for giving me the
opportunity to speak about some of the
exciting solutions we have in the cell
and gene therapy space here at teen wiz
and at brooks life sciences
so
first i wanted to take a quick look at
the topics that we'll be covering
we'll first start with an overview of
our capabilities then we'll perform a
spotlight on processes for aav based
therapies and then i will talk about our
expertise in the biomaterials management
within the r d space
our expertise in clinical trial support
and also highlight our benefits of the
comprehensive supply chain solutions
that we offer
here we've described the general therapy
development pipeline and the individual
stages where some of our offerings will
be applied
from screening and identification to
pre-clinical testing and manufacturing
and throughout clinical trials and
therapy delivery brooks and gene whiz
has many solutions to elevate and
support your program from discovery to
distribution
so let's jump right in to some of our
genomic solutions
this is a closer look at the previous
breakdown here at genewiz we have
options for analytical services under
our next generation sequencing and
sanger based products as well as
synthetic dna offerings
our research grade offerings are
supplemented by both glp compliant and
clia validated options and we have
several proprietary protocols developed
that specifically target the needs of
cell and gene therapy researchers
to highlight our capabilities i want to
take a deeper dive into some of these
proprietary protocols for aav
development
so for those who are not familiar aav or
also known as adeno-associated viruses
is a single-stranded dna virus genome
it has two inverted tandem repeats or
itrs that are at both ends of the genome
and flank the critical genes that are
needed for viral replication and
encapsulation
this encapsulation is necessary as the
delivery vehicle
and is required when being introduced
into a host or a patient
now in recombinant aav production for
therapy three plasmids containing those
critical replication and encapsulation
genes as well as that gene product
that's going to be delivered are
transfected into a packaged cell line
that cell line then produces the aav
particles that will be used for the
therapy
the transfer plasmid contains the
aforementioned itrs
previous studies have shown that
maintaining the itr throughout the
entire production pipeline from the
plasmid to particle affects the quality
and efficiency of the produced virus
therefore any errors to the itr if left
undetected would reduce reproducibility
of experiments and can cause delays and
translating its use into the clinical
space
so iprs are notoriously difficult to
sequence through due to the inverted
repeat containing a
hairpin secondary structure
further historical limitations to
sequencing hindered high quality
sequencing options to confirm packaged
genomic dna
by addressing constraints at the
recombinant plasma dna level at the top
as well as the aav virus particle stage
shown on the bottom our solutions ensure
a good start for high quality aav
manufacturing
so for the first stage of generating the
plasma dna we have a plasma preparation
and synthesis workflow that is designed
to help confirm maintain and correct ipr
first using our proprietary aav itr
sequencing protocol we can sequence
through the itr hairpins with high
quality this allows us to determine if
the itr is intact
truncated or mutated
depending on the results gene was can
then help correct synthesize and
propagate that plasmid
to highlight the benefits of the
protocols i'd like to first show what
the typical sequencing read looks like
when sequencing across an itr region
the start of the itr hairpin in the
chromatogram is underlined in red
as you can see once the primer reaches
the hairpin there's a complete drop off
in the signal
in comparison our aav itr sanger method
can read through the entirety of the itr
which is shown in that black box
and the reed is good quality and is
maintained throughout the other side
for any researchers using aav libraries
or researchers interested in determining
what an individual itr is in a mixed
population the next generation
sequencing on the pac bio is a great
option
the epac bio provides single molecule
resolution for the entire plasmid at
high accuracy
its chemistry is known to sequence
through gc virtualizations and itrs at
high quality
and this workflow allows for high
throughput types of screening and
analyses where the sanger method is less
feasible
so why is sequencing so important
there are traditional itr confirmation
protocols using digestion analysis which
is really considered the gold standard
in this case study we performed an
enzyme digestion of a plasman product
that will cut the iprs and result in two
bands the bands are that gene of
interest and the remaining backbone
if the right size bands are observed the
traditional assumption is that the itrs
were therefore present and intact and is
released from qc
however when we perform sanger
sequencing across the expected itr
regions we found that one of the arms
had been deleted but not the arm that
contained the enzyme binding site
therefore while digestion analysis
provides a good look at any major
depletions in one of the arms it does
not have the level of resolution that
sequencing can provide
therefore it's important that sequencing
should become part of a standard qc
process
now confirming itr is only half the
issue
now that we can confirm it we can
address the ways to maintain it
now again itrs are known to mutate and
research to spend many resources in
screening and testing to get that right
product
at gene liz we have a proprietary dna
plasmid preparation protocol that
maintains the itr better compared to
existing commercial lines and protocols
in this case we transformed eight
different aav plasmids into several
strains and then we took the colonies
from those strains and screened clones
from each plate using our sanger method
found that the gene was protocols were
best at keeping the itr intact
regardless of which plasmid we are
working with
for the other commercial strains and
methods some fared better than others
but the genus method consistently came
out on top of note our protocols have a
high success rate when generating
large-scale dna preparations such as
midi mega and giga scales
98 of the large-scale dna preparations
that we tested maintained the itr with
the first propagation attempt
while the remaining two percent
we were able to get the correct itr
after a second attempt
for manufacturing we have glp grade
plasmid sequence confirmation services
and also glp dna preparation services
available
our services are compliant with the
fda's 21 cfr part 58 guidelines
we can perform a fully glp-grade
amplification and or digestion analysis
for itr verification
our sanger av itr protocol is available
as a supplement at the research grade
level though we expect to formally
launch the glp option in may 2021
so here we've addressed the issues of
itr confirmation and maintenance at the
plasma level so i'd now like to share
the solutions that we have at the
confirmation of the packaged virus
when it comes to the product that's the
basis of your therapy it's critical to
understand what is being packaged
impurities can include defective or
truncated particles residual dna from
other viruses or contaminants from the
original plasmid and the packaging cell
line
now any impurities or incorrect
sequences can trigger unwanted immune
responses therefore measuring the level
of any dna contaminant is important in
understanding the risk of adverse side
effects during clinical use
so we actually used next generation
sequencing to address these concerns
first we confirm the packaged virus via
illumina sequencing and we confirm the
purity of the virus
this method provides deep sequencing of
any dna that can be packaged
the resulting data can be used to screen
against other viral databases
against the host and against the plasmid
sequences to determine the id
on a secondary level the illumina
platform provides some insight into the
mutations and truncations that would
also occur in the virus itself
however there are some limitations here
as the aluminum platform requires the
genome to be fragmented prior to
sequencing therefore the data that's
being generated for variants and
deletions would be performed on the
entire population level
for a deeper look into the exact nature
of the sample then sequence confirmation
on the pac bio is a more ideal situation
this allows to screen the aav without
fragmentation and therefore the
sequences of any potentially mixed
genome sample will be kept intact and
every individual sequence will be
analyzed
this will provide physical confirmation
of those truncations those variants and
the itrs at the single molecule level
avoiding the need of any inference or
sequence assembly
further next generation sequencing can
be used to
profile the patient or host micro
environment we can perform immune
response profiling and gene expression
profiling during and after the viral
infection or after a treatment
we can further screen for whole
transcripts using long read sequencing
if the treatment affects expression of
specific isoforms
additionally we can perform
characterization of the aav within the
host
and actually characterize the host
itself using any dna sequencing options
now all these services are performed at
the research grade level but clia
validated and clia environment
processing is also available when
required
for aav manufacturing we do have
glp-grade viral or cell bank
confirmation services available
this can be performed using our
pcr-based sanger sequencing pipeline
we accept a variety of materials which
are listed here and all the work is
performed compliant to fda guidelines
so now i'd like to move out of our
analytical workflows and want to talk
more about our capabilities with
biomaterials management in relation to
the cell and gene therapy research and
development space
so circling back to that original
overview brooks life sciences has
expertise in providing consumables
instruments cryogenic solutions and
sample and material storage options
throughout the entire therapy
development pipeline
our unique capabilities provides
traceability
automation and cold chain management to
support any workflow
now sample mishandling like poorly
sealed products or leachable products or
even some temperature variation can be
detrimental to performance of a cellular
product and can impact its overall
quality
at brooks life sciences our consumables
focuses on the quality and the
traceability in that discovery space
our fluidx products can be dual coated
or tri-coated this ensures sample
tracking throughout the entire life
cycle
and also the fluidx products easily fits
into any automation pipeline
brooks life sciences specifically has a
comprehensive selection of instruments
from single tube scanners to full rack
readers which can decode a full rack in
less than one second
to full rack decappers and recappers and
also tube labelers
now our fortitude products includes pcr
consumables ceiling materials and heat
sealing instrumentation microplates for
cell screening and storage
and solutions for sample tracking
and the the sample tracking would
include barcodes and 2d data matrix
codes
the versatile portfolio really
facilitates automation for
reproducibility in any high throughput
process
so when transporting samples within and
even outside of the laboratory it's
critical to maintain cold temperatures
to ensure sample integrity
for high quality sample preparation
protection and preservation our
biostation range allows for reproducible
results
this includes the cool cell which offers
alcohol-free controlled rate freezing at
-1 degrees celsius a minute
the thermoconductive cool racks
which provides temperature uniformity
across all vials when cooling snap
freezing heating or thawing and the cool
box which keeps samples frozen or cold
without ice
the crowdpad courier
cryopad carrier is a great solution that
offers the ease of transport with the
necessity of any temperature tracking
with customizable alarms and reports
this system provides a safe way to
handle temperature sensitive biological
materials and minimizes concerns with
sample integrity during the transit
so for cold storage the biostore 3
platform provides optimized cold chain
and process control for a wide range of
materials and critical reagents
this system includes an onboard software
controller that documents and tracks
user access inventory order history and
temperature trend reports this is key
for any high value samples and reagents
this is also ideal where
any situation that calls for an
automated storage system and provides a
comprehensive management management
system for any laboratory
accordingly brooks offers off-site
storage and management services or an
online support
on site support with lim systems to help
track and maintain any critical products
that you may have
for off-site storage we have many global
repositories with the ability to track
samples using a secure system including
role-based security and solutions that
are fda-21cfr
part 11 compliant
for on-site management we offer workflow
and tracking using our linfinity
software now infinity is easy to set up
and also offers customizable features
that allows researchers and laboratories
to tailor the system to fit their
specific needs
next i want to move on to the support
that we have for clinical trials
now cell and gene therapies have brought
a new paradigm to clinical trials
traditional drug therapies have
established regulatory pathways that
take a compound or a molecule biologic
through each stage from development to
phase 3 trials in a very standardized
manner
typically the number of patients grow
from the tens in phase one to the
thousands in phase three
and once approved these drugs are then
targeted to treat tens of thousands
hundreds of thousands or even millions
of patients
dell and gene therapies on the other
hand tend to be a more targeted
population where traditional drugs have
been ineffective
the trial sizes tend to be much smaller
with patients in the single digits at
the phase one
and only in the hundreds at phase three
it's also common for phases to be
combined for trials for example one and
two or two and three
as the patients tend to be very ill and
are out of the traditional therapy
options
brook supports advanced therapies at the
pre-clinical and clinical level in
multiple stages so we discussed quite a
few options under our client lab
operations such as providing the
controlled consumables the reagent
management and storage and the
analytical and production services
for our material management solutions we
have the ability to have 24 7 visibility
and access to the samples and products
regardless of where they are across the
globe and with the focus on sample and
material management we provide rapid
retrievals of up to a thousand items
within 24 hours so you can always get
the right material to the right person
at the right time so whether that's a
researcher that's using a sample to
measure the effectiveness of a therapy
or if it's for a patient that's awaiting
for their personalized therapy
for pre-clinical analysis variables can
be the root cause of irreproducible data
now birth quality processes ensure that
all samples are handled in a consistent
manner and in a way that minimizes
sample variability
whether it's through the use of our
temperature controlled work in progress
cards or our expert staff that's
extensively trained in the proper
handling of any sample types our staff
ensures that samples will be handled
with utmost care and the with
the greatest attention to detail
in addition brooks is able to provide
quality control assays in-house whether
it's verifying that the transfection
process was effective or verifying the
identity of a cell line or product
all of these offerings applies to any
phase of the trial whether it be a small
size or a larger population study
all of our solutions are easily scalable
and can be performed for research use or
under cap and clia compliant workflows
further brooks has inline processing
laboratories that use the same process
across the globe to ensure that your
assays are reflective of true study
results and not the variation you may
see between different processing
laboratories
from basic fractionation to pbmc
isolation
for crop preservation and nucleic acid
extraction through genomic and
transcriptomic analyses our processes
are well established to minimize any
variables
lastly i'd now like to spotlight some of
our supply chain solutions in the cell
in gene therapy delivery space
several unique logistical challenges
arise with cell and gene therapy
delivery
so it's really important to identify the
right partner who offers flexible
solutions to safeguard the integrity and
quality of your drug product while
meeting regulatory requirements and
mitigating supply chain risks
when it comes to advanced therapies
accounting for the uniqueness of the
product and the scalability of the
process remains a concern
these therapies can be inherently unique
they are usually very high value
and in some therapies like allogenic
therapies
it's often produced in small lots
autologous therapies are individualized
down to a single patient
and the product often requires a unique
storage need scaling up protocols to
address all of these unique needs often
requires complex and time-critical
processes and it often needs a
significant investment
most supply chains are also set up for
warmer temperature storage like
traditional refrigeration temperatures
and sample tracking with chain of
custody and chain of identity is very
important for every single sample
at brooks we harness the strength of the
n of one approach
this means that we treat every sample as
a nf1 and use the existing
infrastructure built at brooks and
leverage our expertise in chain of
custody tracking capabilities
so brooks ensures safe and secure cold
chain storage transport and chain of
custody at every stage of the workflow
regardless of the therapy type
from sample collection to product
manufacturing
and distribution to end to end user we
have options to assist you at every
stage
our cold chain storage and inventory
model can be categorized in three ways
storage at brooks storage on-site and
the hybrid storage model
the option that a company may choose is
dependent on their life cycle and based
on their overall capacity needs
when lower volume
is is the current source complete
outsourcing with brooks might make the
most sense
then when a company is at a fuller scale
they might want to purchase and insource
more their storage or go with a hybrid
model
now for on-site and
storage and self-management we offer a
variety of automated storage and
inventory management systems like the
biostore 3 that was mentioned earlier
for sites this includes sponsors
contract manufacturing organizations and
logistic providers
we can also assist with storage at
clinical sites
but regardless of the strategy chosen
any combination allows for real-time
inventory visibility and data
connectivity between all units and
sites all of our coltrane logistics
solutions includes chain of custody and
audit trail tracking
robust solutions it also includes some
automated systems and a very fast
turnaround
we have many licenses and accreditations
that are listed on the right-hand side
and all of these accreditations apply to
the logistics of distribution described
on the left
so in summary we've described several
options as part of the cell and gene
therapy workflow that facilitates a
robust development pipeline
genius aav protocols can read maintain
and prepare itr samples with high
quality and reliability
our ngs capabilities allows for a high
throughput plasmid screening and
provides aav genome solutions beyond
sequence confirmation
brooks provides expertise in
traceability automation and cold chain
management through offering high quality
consumables instruments and cryogenic
solutions by the fluid x and fortitude
consumables bio efficient products
biostorm
biostore platform and lymphanity systems
and brook supply chain offerings allows
for cold chain logistics that reflect
the unique nature of the samples while
continuing to provide a high level of
sample accountability in a convenient
scalable but customizable model
now with that i'm happy to take any
questions thank you for your time
thank you dr louis for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar if you have
any questions you want to ask please do
so now just click on that ask a question
box
and so let's get started
we have already some several questions
coming in dr louie
are there any limitations to the aav itr
singer sequencing service
that's a great question so yes some
recombinant av plasmids contain a
homopolymeric g region that precedes the
five prime end of the itr region so
sequencing through this g region with
existing sayer methods have been very
challenging and even the itr sequencing
method suffers from that same difficulty
so what you'll see is that the signal
will drop along the poly t sequence and
causes a premature termination without
extending that hairpin
so currently unfortunately there's
really no good solution to overcome this
hurdle
however our a the itr sequencing method
is capable of sequencing from the
reverse direction through that hairpin
and that poly c repeat so it does
improve the data quality and the read
length in this region going from the
other direction
thank you so much now which brook site
is used to store patient samples from
the clinical trials
yeah so
brooks has eight biobanks um that are
located on three continents um and and
those those biobanks store clinical
samples so the primary
locations though um are in indianapolis
in indiana in the u.s um gresham in
germany and europe and also in singapore
and in beijing china
thank you so much and again i want to
thank our audience for these great
questions now what kind of suitability
do tubes and plates from brook life
sciences have
for storing cell lines and pcr
applications
yeah um so as i mentioned earlier the
fluid x tubes is really great for cell
line storage so the tubes themselves are
manufactured using a high quality virgin
polypropylene
and it's also manufactured in an iso
class eight clean room environment so
that means there's going to be no
detectable leachables or extractables
and they're definitely endotoxin and
dnase and rnas free so it also has a
great temperature range from minus 196
celsius to 121 and that makes it really
ideal for storing um cell lines at a
really cold temperature but please note
it might not be the best for like a
liquid
liquid nitrogen type of storage
when it comes to the pcr the fortitude
plates are manufactured under iso
conditions as well
and we use the virgin medical grade
polymers there so the injection molding
is done in an iso class 7 clean room
though
so it does ensure a high quality
standards and also again to make sure
that they're free of any like leachables
that can interfere with your pcr
thank you very much and our next
audience member wants to know how does
brooks ensure appropriate inventory
levels of critical reagents
that are maintained
so um i assume this is referring to the
biomaterial storage component
so
at the start of every new project that
that's kind of initiated there's a
brooks project manager that works with
the clients to define what material is
going to be stored when that part is all
set up
there can be alert and action limits
that can be used as triggers so
there would be like a automatic reorder
point uh notification
doctor we have time for one more
question
are you able to generate itr mutants for
efficiency for efficacy testing and
screening
so we do have capabilities to perform de
novo synthesis of any of the itrs
or we can use our itr correction
protocols to mutate them so the method
that we use will be highly dependent on
the mutant type that's being requested
but we do have a lot of experience just
making
entirely new aav vectors and and the
vector backbones completely de novo um
so we're happy to kind of discuss what
options you are specifically interested
in
dr louis thank you for your time today
for your important research and your
presentation and before we go i want to
thank our audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions and
i want you to know that this webcast
will now be available on demand through
april of 2022
we hope you enjoy the event
take care and stay healthy bye bye
everyone